manuela absente deux trois quatre
absents 4,9 pour cent des élèves du
secondaire sont considérés comme
absentéisme autrement dit ces collégiens
et lycéens sèchent les cours deux jours
ou plus par mois comment faire baisser
ce chiffre dans les années 70 une idée
émerge et fera polémique
les élèves sont avertis que toute
situation irrégulière peut entraîner le
retrait des bourses et la suspension du
versement des allocations familiales
la suspension des allocations familiales
une mesure qui sera sans cesse proposer
et qui sera sans cesse source de
polémique au début des années 2000 dans
certains départements une convention est
signée entre la caisse d'allocations
familiales et les collèges et la
suspension est mis en place au cas par
cas où nous écrivons immédiatement dans
les meilleurs délais à la famille en lui
indiquant donc ce rappel à la loi qu'il
s'agit de respecter cette obligation de
scolarité et de d'assiduité et que en
cas de non respect il y aura possibilité
de suspendre ou de supprimer les
prestations familiales dues pour cet
enfant mais du côté des parents la
menace financière n'a pas l'air de
fonctionner l'acte en lui-même ne savait
rien du tout parce que c'est pas pour ça
qu'il a été plus souvent à l'école je
dirais même que bon à la fin de toute
façon ils en voulaient plus en 2005
après les émeutes dans les banlieues
le gouvernement veut généraliser cette
mesure après de nombreux débats une loi
est votée mais elle ne sera jamais
appliquée
cinq ans plus tard sarkozy est à
l'elysée et ressort le fameux dossier de
la suspension des allocations les
allocations familiales seront supprimés
pour les familles qui ne se préoccupe
pas de l'absentéisme de leurs enfants
il a encore débat polémique mais au
final la mesure est appliquée pour
l'année scolaire
1011 2012 sur tout le territoire
français et jeunes auraient porté bilan
de la mesure sur les trois cent mille
élèves absentéistes pendant l'année
scolaire 619 familles ont vu leurs
allocations suspendues
un résultat satisfaisant à droite une
mesure inutile pour la gauche
quelques mois après la communication de
ces chiffres changement de locataire à
l'elysée changement de vision c'est donc
une autre mesure emblématique de l'ère
sarkozy qui est supprimée la fameuse loi
ciotti qui permet de suspendre les
allocations aux parents d'un enfant trop
souvent absents mise en place sublime et
essai dans certains départements
abandonné la suspension des allocations
familiales des parents d'élèves
absentéistes devient un serpent de mer
idéologique mais pendant ce temps
l'absentéisme chronique concerne plus de
6 % des élèves des lycées d'enseignement
général et plus de 15% des élèves des
lycées professionnels
[Musique]